hello there I'm Nastasia Tayan Doha this
is Al Jazeera and you've been watching
our special coverage of the takier Syria
earthquakes one month on now those
Quakes have given rise to plenty of
anger about the poor implementation of
building codes in tokie the country will
also be voting in a presidential
election in May and the opposition
parties have just named their joint
candidate against President erdogan
Let's cross over to angrow where the
announcement was just made synonym
Costco joins us now live from the cinema
just what do we know about Kamal
kilichirolu
is the leader of the main opposition
Republican party and he has been in that
chair for a long time and he's known to
be he's known to have lost nearly every
election against that he ran against
President rejected but after the failed
military coup in Turkey just as a
reaction to the crackdowns he had a walk
a kilometer a thousand hundreds of
kilometers of uh walk to show solidarity
with people and it to to to protest
against what he called the Injustice
Decisions by the government after that
has increased his popularity and within
the last one and a half years he
gathered with the second largest
opposition party e-party which is an
offshoot of the of the Nationalist party
and four other parties around the table
and they have been working on some
principles and those all six parties are
from different political backgrounds
with different ideologies from left to
Islam is some former up party
offshoot and now he's been named as the
candidate of the opposition
you described a very diverse opposition
there just how United is the opposition
heading towards me
well deleted on the second largest
opposition party party leader marath
College who was also who is also a
former interior minister of late 90s and
through here and she she had a
disagreement with a table of six with
other five members of this opposition
Alliance because as former election I
the second largest opposition leader the
polls the public pools have suggested
that Istanbul May recre
were the potential names who could win
the election against President
who has been the leader of this country
for 22 years but kamarcolesterol the
main opposition leader who has been
saying that he wouldn't come up as a
presidential candidate unless he's
really named by the others he he showed
that he was willing to be a candidate
and in the last meeting of the table six
we we have been hearing that a metal
action I was against this and that's why
she pulled out of the table because she
didn't feel comfortable with the
decision and she said she suggested that
the the candidate should be what the
public polls address but after some
mediation meetings now they have come up
with an idea that may no position leader
is the presidential candidate and all
five other leaders of the alliance
member parties will become vice
presidents along with Istanbul and
Ankara May so this is what they have
agreed on finally they came around this
idea after some talks it'll be a very
interesting election indeed there in May
Cinema across that for us in Ankara
thank you so much synonym